ومع اقتراب الذكرى السنويه الاولى للحرب
في اوكرانيا يبدو الوضع في ميادين القتال
مختلفا تماما عن الاسابيع الاولى من الحرب
ومغايرا للصوره التي رسمها لمسار المعارك
صحيفه الجارديان البريطانيه كشفت ان هناك
تقييمات متناقضه لقدره روسيا علشان هجوم
جديد مهم رغم ان كبار المسؤولين
الاوكرانيين حذروا مرارا وتكرارا من ان
موسكو تخطط لبذل جهد جديد كبير هذا العام
على الرغم من التعبئه التي اعلن عنها
بوتين سبتمبر من العام الماضي يعتقد
محللون ان القدرات الروسيه قد تدهورت بسبب
الحرب وان اولئك الذين يتوقعون اعاده
موسكو غزوه جارتها على غرار ما حدث العام
الماضي مخطئون فمنذ اكثر من سته اشهر
تحاول مجموعه فاجنر والجيش الروسي احتلال
مدينه باخمت الواقعه في شرق اوكرانيا ومن
شان الاستيلاء على بخمس ان يمنح القوات
الروسيه نقطه انطلاق للتقدم الى مدينتين
اكبر في الغرب هما اكرم تورسك
[موسيقى]